then we say civilizations fragile do you
mean because of this covet 19 that's
going on right now
what's that never this is thing ya know
it's like some people just get a copy
over other people it gets much worse I
mean this certainly has taken over the
mind space of the world to a degree that
is quite shocking yeah well I don't know
where that's what's crazy it's like you
go back to November nothing now here we
are December January February March
April May six months totally different
world I kind of saw this whole thing
play out in China before it played out
in the u.s. so it's kind of like
watching the same movie again but in
English I think the thievery the the
mortality rate is is much less than what
is then what say the World Health
Organization said it was it's very much
much less I probably at least order of
magnitude less well it it seems to be
very deadly two very specific kinds of
people and people with specific problems
yeah I mean if you're you can look at
the mortality statistics you know by age
and whether they have como do it come
over it is like do they have like
basically existing conditions and by age
and you know if you're below 60 and and
have no serious health issues the
probability of death is extremely low
it's not zero but it's extremely low
they didn't think that this was the case
though when they first started to lock
down the country do you think that it's
a situation where once they proceed in a
certain way it's very difficult to
correct course that's most like people
really wanted a panic baby is quite
quite crazy but in some places a panic
is deserved right like if you're in the
ICU in Manhattan and people are dying
left and right and everyone's on into
baiters and it's a it's it seems like
when you see all these people on
ventilators and
so many of them are dying and you see
these nurses are dying and doctors are
getting sick in some places that fear is
justified but then in other places
you're you're reading these stories
about hospitals that are essentially
half-empty they're they're having to
furlough doctors and nurses because
there's no work for them most of the
hospitals in the United States right now
half empty or in some cases they're at
30% capacity and is this because they've
decided to forego elective procedures
and and and normal things that people
would have to go to the hospital for yes
I mean we're and we're not talking about
just some of these elective procedures
are quite important yeah it's like you
have a bad heart disease yes you're mean
you need a you know triple bypass it's
like sort of elective but if you don't
get it done in time it's you're gonna
die yeah it's electives weird word
elective it's not like hey I wanna
there's no like plastic surgery it's
like it's more like like my my hip is
I'm an extreme pain because my my hips
blown out or my knee and I don't want to
go to the hospital I can't go to the
hospital to you know people in extreme
pain feel that need a kidney you know
like people that I have like quite
serious issues that are choosing not to
go out of fear so I think it's it's a
problem it's not good it seems like the
state of public perception is shifting
it is like people are taking some deep
breaths and relaxing and because of the
statistics of I mean and and essentially
across the board it's being recognized
that it's not as fatal as we thought it
was still danger is still worse than the
flu but not as bad as we thought or are
we feared it could be I'm going to
actively the mortality is as much lower
like at least a factor of 10 maybe a
factor of 50 lower than initially
thought do you think that the current
way we're handling this the social
distance saying the mask the locking
down is it does this make sense is it
adequate or or do you think that we
should
move back to Italy's closer to where we
used to be well I think proper hygiene
is a good thing no matter what you know
wash your hands and you know and if
you're if you're coughing stay home or
wear a mask is not good you know if I
could do that in Japan that's like
normal yeah if you're if you're Lu you
wear a face mask and you know cough on
people I think that that would be a
great thing to to adopt in general
throughout the world I'm washing your
hands is also good I think that there's
this to apply some silver linings here
then in improved uh you know hygiene
yeah and an awareness of potential yes
and I think this has shaken up the the
system systems like smart moribund with
loudly as layers of bureaucracy and I
think that we have cut through some of
that bureaucracy
and if we you know at some point there
probably will be a pandemic with with a
with with a high mortality rate you know
that was a debate about like what's high
but I mean like something that's killing
a lot of twenty-year-old would say like
we're like it's yes if you have like
Ebola type of mortality Spanish flu
something yeah actually just some
healthy people yeah yeah yeah
but it's a yeah like like killing large
numbers of young healthy people that
that's you know defined that as like
high mortality then that this is at
least practice for something like that
and I think there's this you know given
it's just a matter a matter of time that
there will be eventually some some such
pandemic I think there's a good chance I
it's highly likely I think coming out of
this that we will develop vaccines that
we didn't have before
for corona viruses and other other
viruses and and possibly it cures for
for these and are I'm standing of
viruses of thus nature has improved
dramatically because if the attention
that it's received so buzzers definitely
some you know a lot of silver lining
here and potentially if we act correctly
yeah yeah yeah there's uh I think you
there will be some amount of lining here
no matter what hopefully more purpose of
lighting and less yeah
so yeah this is this is a looks like
kind of like a practice run for
something that had that that had a
potential that might in the future have
a serious like a really high mortality
rate and we kind of got to go through
this with with without without it being
something that kills you know vast
numbers of young healthy people there's
two arguments right the one argument is
we need to keep going protect the weak
protect the sick but let's open up the
economy the other argument is stop
placing money over human lives and let's
shelter in place until we come up with
some sort of a decision and let's figure
out some way to develop some sort of a
universal income universal basic income
plan or something like that to feed
people during the during this time
wellyes transition I think this uh yeah
yeah as I said right yeah my pay is if
somebody wants to stay home they should
stay home
I've said something doesn't want stay
home they should not be compelled to
stay home that's my opinion do you think
if somebody doesn't like that well
that's my opinion
so the now yeah the this notion though
that you you know you can just sort of
sand checks out everybody and and things
would be fine it's not true obviously
the there's some people have this absurd
like view that the economy is like some
magic horn of plenty like it just makes
stuff stuff you know what it just
there's a magic word aplenty and what
the goods and services they just come
from this magic corn appointee and then
if like if somebody has more stuff than
somebody else's because they took more
from this magic horn of plenty now let
me just break it to the fools out there
if you don't make stuff there's no stuff
yeah so if you don't make the food
if you don't process the food you know
transport the food and the alchemor the
weather you know medical treatment
you're getting your teeth fixed or
there's no stuff I would become detached
from reality you can't just legislate
money and sit and solve these things if
you don't make stuff there is no stuff
obviously we'll run out of the stores
run out of the you know it's like hold
the machine just grinds to a halt what's
the way out of this what do you think is
like if if you have the president's ear
or if people wanted to just listen you
openly what do you think is the way out
of this let's suppose to clear up the
data clear up the data so like I said I
just so make sure we recorded as Co but
only if it is somebody has been tested
has received a positive positive
covetous not if they simply have
symptoms one of like a hundred symptoms
and then if if it is a covert death it
must be separate or was this was covert
a primary primary reason for death or
did they also have stage three cancer or
heart disease emphysema and got hit by
bus ant had covered you have read all
this stuff about that about them
diagnosing people as a Cova death
despite other variables this is not a
this is not a this is not a a question
this is what is occurring and where are
you reading this from where are you
getting this from the public health
health officials have literally said
this is not this is not a question mark
right but this is never this is
unprecedented right like if someone had
the flu but also had a heart attack they
would assume that that person died of a
heart attack yes yeah so this is
unprecedented is this because this is
such a popular I don't wanna use that
word the wrong way but that's what I
mean a popular subject and financial
incentives yes and like I said this is
not some sort of it
mara Lightman of sort of hospital
administrators it's just they're in it
they're there in a tough in a tough spot
here they actually don't have enough
patience to pay everyone but without
fooling wait furloughing doctors and and
firing staff and yeah this is the
running potentially going bankrupt so so
then they're like okay well the similar
spill says if you know we get all this
you know money if we say if if they have
put sack over death I'm like okay they
coughed before they died they in fact
they're not even diagnosis code but they
simply if you had weakness a cough
shortness of breath frankly I'm not sure
how you died without those things yeah
you yeah right there's so many different
things you could attribute to Cova -
there's so many symptoms
there's diarrhea headaches dehydration
yeah Goff yes but to be clear you you
you don't even need to have gotten a
covert a crisis you simply need to have
had one of yea many symptoms and then
have died for some reason and it's
covert so so then it makes the death
count look very high and then we're then
stuck in a bind because it looks like
the death counts super high and not
going down like it should be and now so
then we should keep whatever you know
keep you know the shelter in place stuff
there and and keep people in their home
you know confine people their homes so
we need to get break out of this this
we're stuck in a loop yeah and I think
the way to break out of this loop is to
have clarity of information first of all
we need real data you need it just parse
out the data don't don't lump it all
together you know and if you give if you
get people just parse out the data
better clear clearer information about
like set was this an actual code of a
diagnosis or was it a did they get the
test and if you test came back positive
or do they just have some symptoms just
parsed up those two out and then parse
out just
if somebody died did they die would did
they eat but that they even have a
covert test or did they just have one of
many symptoms like like look how do you
die without weakness I don't know it's
impossible basically yeah good point
you're gonna die you're gonna have
shortness of breath weakness and again
you might kaufe little so so was it
quantified what was it yeah did that
person that did they actually have a
covert test and and the tests come back
positive
and then if they died did they die where
we're covered was it isn't had to be the
the main course but it was a significant
contributor to their death or was it not
a significant contributor to the death
right it's not as simple as just because
you had Kovac Kovac killed you it's
definitely not right yeah yeah I mean
people die all the time they have like
flu and yes other colds and well we
don't say that they died of those flu
and other colds if you want more advice
wisdom guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable continue to believe and
I'll see you there
and like I'm already thinking about like
18 months from now and everyone's like
man that wasn't so bad